how much does president donald trump
hate section 230
the controversial law that gives
internet service providers
website operators and social media
platforms broad immunity from
legal responsibility for user-generated
content
he's threatened to veto funding for the
military unless congress completely
terminates the law which also allows
social media sites to moderate or ban
speech they don't like
trump is joined in his contempt for
section 230 by joe biden
section 230 should be revoked
immediately
should be revoked number one democrats
argue that section 230 allows hate
speech and misinformation to proliferate
and to throw elections
while republicans say it's used to
squelch conservative voices
in the public square enter ajit pai the
chairman of the federal communication
commission
in october after president trump went on
a tear about twitter and facebook
restricting access to a new york post
story
critical of joe biden's son hunter pai
said the fcc would be looking to clarify
section 230. even though he's announced
he's stepping down on january 20th
and that congress has ultimate
responsibility for passing laws
governing online speech
what pai does in his final weeks could
have a lasting
impact i spoke with him right before the
reason foundation the nonprofit that
publishes reason tv
awarded him the sixth annual savis award
for privatization
because of his market-friendly policies
including facilitating the growth of 5g
networks and ending fcc regulation of
internet service providers
commonly known as net neutrality in
october
pi said that many advance an overly
broad interpretation of the law
that in some cases shields social media
companies from consumer protection laws
in a way that has no basis in the text
of section 230.
social media companies have a first
amendment right to free speech
he continued but they do not have a
first amendment right to a special
immunity denied
to other media outlets such as
newspapers and broadcasters
in our interview pai talked more about
transparency
than repeal a lot of these social media
platforms
aren't transparent about what algorithms
they use how they essentially decide
what goes and what doesn't go if there's
upfront transparency
i think generally speaking americans can
work around that and understand that
whereas now it's sort of a black box
into which people import
all of their preconceived views or
perhaps mistaken views about
what's going on what's not he seems
convinced that if only people knew why
different platforms made certain
decisions
the system would be more fair the
platform would need to kind of
explain how their algorithms work and
why
this type of content is going to get
this sort of treatment
and this type of content is going to get
something else i think the gist of it is
show your work as my math teacher used
to tell me back in fifth grade is
okay you know we know that you've
reached this conclusion but what was the
reason that got you there and
i think that's something that would
serve everyone in the internet economy
but
leaving it up to the platforms to decide
whether or not to reveal
how they moderate content would be more
in keeping with pi's light touch
approach to regulation
if consumers want social media platforms
that explain themselves better
nothing stopping them from screaming
bloody murder when the services act
poorly
and ultimately taking their business
elsewhere although squelching access to
the new york post hunter biden story was
reprehensible increased government
regulation of such services
is surely a worse outcome pai emphasized
that
congress not the fcc needs to lead on
what happens next
our role here is relatively
circumscribed all we're doing is
proposing to look at the immunity
provision itself and to see
whether or not terms like good faith
require clarifications
are you confident you know that the
government of all people and that
congress is going to be able to
rule with a light touch i mean the
hallmark of your
administration uh and you know has been
a light touch
towards regulation both of technology as
well as of kind of speech where do you
think that ends up i would like to think
that over the last three and a half
years
we've been very consistent in saying
that at the end of the day
markets as opposed to the government
deliver far more value to american
consumers and whether it is a
spectrum auction or the deployment of
infrastructure or
the content that goes over the internet
that generally speaking what we've tried
to do
is enlarge the square and make sure that
the markets based on the aggregated
decisions of millions of individual
consumers
as opposed to someone like me is the
person making that determination
if pi is vague about what his fcc might
recommend
before he steps down and is replaced by
joe biden's pick for chairman
he is unambiguously concerned that
online free speech
is under attack you know that quote
misattributed to voltaire
i may disagree with what you say but
i'll fight for the deaths for your
your right to say it what do you think
the percentage of americans who would
agree with that now is
20 25. i very much am worried about
where that's going
everyone is looking for the slightest
hint of hereticism from the other side
or even from their own side and looking
to penalize it
that's just not the america that i want
to see we've grown up generally
speaking most of us with a culture of
free speech and free expression and i
think we've often taken that for granted
once that culture phrase who puts it
back together it's not going to be a
politician it's not going to be a
regulator
it has to be the aggregated decisions of
millions of americans to say
we want pluralism again and there's
every reason to believe that biden's
pick to replace pi
will work to bring far more government
interference to the workings of the
internet
including when it comes to section 230.
that's what the future of online speech
looks like right now
and it's not comforting